emotions are hard like really hard and
sometimes words just don't do our
feelings justice but what if you didn't
have to talk about your emotions what if
you could express them simply by making
music that's the idea behind a new app
called Cove from design studio humane
engineering Cove is like a mood journal
only instead of using words to express
how you feel you use music to build a
song we drop stones into a flowing river
as the tide washes over the digital
rocks they play a sound kind of like
pins plucking the teeth of a music box
you can change the key of your song by
selecting a new mood filter choosing
playful for instance will give your song
a cheerful
major chord tone while something like
struggling blankets your melody with an
ominous minor chord value when you're
done you can add tags and a note that
explained in more detail how you're
feeling at that given moment
the apps creators sake Cove was designed
with teenagers in mind but we think it's
useful for anyone interested in
monitoring their emotional health
because let's be honest I think we all
know even adults could use a little help
in expressing how they feel sometimes